[Musique]
les pôles des territoires extrême qui ne
ressemble à rien d'autre sur terre
chaque fois que j'y veille jean jaurès
encore un peu plus imprégné seul endroit
que j'adore j'ai appris énormément
autant par la beauté de la nature la
bonté des animaux mais aussi la beauté
humaine donc les inuit qui vivent là bas
le parcours immersif nous permet
d'accompagner l'aventurier et
photographe animalier dans ses
expéditions en ces terres d'extrême se
sortait quand on est dans l'article ça
veut dire brune les grosses tempêtes la
glace qui je suis je suis toujours parti
trois jours à la dérive sur un morceau
de glace où on est venu me récupérer un
petit avion les écrans géants
la scénographie et la musique de jean
michel blay contribué à nous dépayser en
nous immergeant dans l'épaule
on avait du matériel extraordinaire
entre les mains les images de mario a
fait et c'était de trouver comment les
organiser pour raconter quelque chose
qui allait à la fois nous faire voyager
nous faire rêver nous transmettre
l'immensité de ses paysages la mario cyr
a plongé plus de douze mille fois dans
ses eaux glacées entouré de bêtes qu'on
dirait venu d'une autre planète
ce que moi j'aimerais assez de faire
comprendre aux gens ici c'est quand on
regarde de la classe les gens pensent
souvent c'est comme un plancher vie
absolument rien en dessous et celle
endroits dans le monde où il ya
probablement le plus de biodiversité un
territoire extrême où le danger est
omniprésent mais aussi un territoire
fragile
on voulait tellement pas être
moralisateur tellement poète dramatique
étant donné tout ce qu'on a vécu avec la
pandémie on voulait donner du beau avoir
un sentiment d mais quelque chose c'est
quand on tombe en amour avec une image
un d'écart mais on a envie de le
protéger
pas de site dans cette nouvelle
production d'eloise mais la même volonté
de surprendre et d'émerveiller sur les
glaces avec mario cyr c'est une plongée
vers l'inconnu un voyage vers une terre
glacial mais d'une beauté à nous faire
fondre le coeur ici n'est bien lexandre
chartier radio canada montréal